tomás sabe que un poliedro tiene área de
superficie de 40 centímetros cuadrados
la siguiente red tiene aristas de 5
centímetros y 2 centímetros es posible
que ésta sea una red para el poliedro
bueno primero vamos a marcar los lados
de 5 y 2 centímetros
aquí nos indican que este lado es de 5
centímetros entonces todos los que están
marcados así con doble marca también son
de 5 centímetros este es de 5
centímetros este es de 5 centímetros
este también y estos 2 también tienen
doble marca y por lo tanto son de 5
centímetros cada 15 centímetros 5
centímetros y de manera similar podemos
marcar los lados que miden 2 centímetros
que están marcados nada más con una
rayita entonces ese sería de 2 este
también esto también sería de 2 aunque
no parece al parecer el dibujo no está
hecho a escala pero bueno nos marcan con
esta rayita que miden lo mismo este
también sería de 2 este también este
también y me faltan unos poquitos verdad
el de acá
y el de acá el de acá todos esos miden
dos centímetros vale muy bien ahora algo
que no tenemos que hacer para este
problema pero que siempre es divertido
hacer es intentar visualizar cómo se ve
este poliedro una vez que lo armamos es
decir una vez que doblamos su red y al
parecer éste nos va a quedar como un
prisma rectangular déjame dibujarlo por
acá vale voy a tomar este color azul
para para indicar este los lados vamos a
empezar con la base la base la voy a
pintar es más déjame cambiar de color la
base la voy a pintar de color naranja y
va a ser esta de acá
algo de este estilo entonces ahí
tendríamos la base de nuestro prisma
rectangular donde las dimensiones son 2
y 5 2 y 5 sale este 3 este rectángulo de
acá sería este rectángulo este
rectángulo de acá ahora déjame tomar
este que voy a pintar con este color
azul este de acá pues lo podemos doblar
hacia acá para para que quede
perpendicular y se convertiría más o
menos en destacar en esta cara de acá
vale ahí tenemos esa cara rectangular
que está pegada a través de esta arista
con con la cara de abajo con la cara
inferior vale que igual tiene 5 de lado
y tiene ahora dos de alto de aquí para
acá serían dos voy a tomar ahora este en
color amarillo y este que es un cuadrado
verdad mide dos y dos
entonces se quedaría pegado por acá por
acá dos y dos
sería esa cara como de atrás vamos con
esta cara de enfrente más o menos en
frente verdad que correspondería a esta
porque está pegada a la naranja iba a
quedar pegada a la amarilla entonces
quedaría como por acá
a ver si no me sale muy chueco pero
bueno espero que al menos veas la idea
ahí tenemos esa cara voy con la de hoy
con este cuadrado primero este cuadrado
lo voy a pintar en color verde que sería
este de acá eso sí quedó feo este de acá
ahí tenemos el cuadrado de 2 x 2 y
finalmente esta sería la cara superior
la voy a poner en color blanco color
blanco bueno algunos dicen que el blanco
no es color pero bueno no importa estoy
aquí va a estar pintado en blanco baja
entonces esta figura este poliedro se
vería así es un prisma rectangular pero
regresemos a la pregunta original como
le haríamos para determinar el área de
la superficie de este prisma bueno pues
tendríamos que sumar el área de cada una
de sus caras entonces vamos a encontrar
el área de cada cara esta cara de acá
tiene la 25 y 2 y es un rectángulo de
modo que su área sería 5 por 2 o sea 10
de manera similar este rectángulo
también es de 5 por 2 entonces el área
es 10 este también y este de acá también
tiene base 2 base 5 altura 2 y por lo
tanto su área es 10 y si vamos a los
cuadrados pues tienen lado 2 por lo
tanto el área de este es 2 al cuadrado o
sea 4 y el área de éste también es 2 al
cuadrado o sea 4 entonces ya tenemos el
área de cada una de las caras y por lo
tanto el área de superficie sería la
suma de todo eso que es 10 más 10 más 10
+ 10 y 40 más 44 44 48 entonces el área
sería de 48 centímetros cuadrados
respondiendo la pregunta
es posible que ésta sea una red para el
poliedro de tomás pues no porque el
poliedro de tomás tiene área de
superficie de 40 centímetros cuadrados y
esta red es para un poliedro con área de
48 centímetros cuadrados de modo que la
respuesta es no